[موسيقى]
الفودو
anoano Seam Wars rexat موظف دائم
طارة
ليس
[موسيقى]
نعم ، اسمي كينتارو ساكاي
مهنتي هي إنتاج وبيع Nishikigoi في محافظة هيروشيما.
هذا Nishiki-koi رهيب ، لكني كنت أقوم بعمل أسلافي لأجيال
الطريقة الأولى التي تعلمت بها كيفية تنمية هذا النوع من الأشياء كانت من والدي. إنه أمر طبيعي حقًا.
أعني أنني توليت هذه الوظيفة الآن
حسنًا ، إنه من هذا القبيل
يوجد حوالي 70 نوعًا في الغرفة الرئيسية للصوت الواعي وعند تقسيمها.
نوع Nishikigoi الذي أفعله هو الأحمر والأبيض
حسنًا ، أكاتسو شيرو نوكو وتايشو سانشوكو أحمر وأسود وأبيض
فقط هذين النوعين
الفعل
سيظل البحث العادي يعيش لمدة 20 إلى 30 عامًا
ومع ذلك ، فإن ذروة الجمال لا تزال تبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات.
أيضا
حبي هو النظام الأول
شخصية رائعة
وهو لامع
مشروع bd 6 d يبحث عن صفحة رياضية sql
نورماد صابر 2 الشكل إسفين نودلز حتى بار مقعد خشبي نقار الخشب
خام
الحديث عن عنصر هام من الحب noshiku ، بعد كل الماء
بعد كل شيء كيف تصنع المياه الصالحة للشرب وكيف
إن صنع الطعام اللذيذ وإعطائه للعمل هو العامل الأكثر أهمية.
[موسيقى]
نيشيكي كوي لها طعم متطور للغاية.
أنا أفهم أن هذا الطعم لذيذ وسيء.
شكل Arkham مع كرة من الفرو تشير إلى سمكة
هنري براج
ويب ديسيبل للقيام في 1 ش موقف سيارة عيد الفصح
الجسم هذا شكل الجسم رائع
أيضًا ، يصبح لمعان نسيج اللون مهمًا جدًا.
ملكة جمال لأول مرة عام 2000 حتى 2020 هذا العام 10 مرات
أخذت البطل
rds للحصول على سعيد ders ore ga n n gram boo
لي أن أفعل bx السراويل الاسمية ب
حسنًا ، إنها الأسطورة ، التي فازت بالبطولة في بطولة All Japan العام الماضي.
Koide هذا الصوت في ذلك المزاد
إنه حب 203 مليون متبقي ، محققًا رقمًا قياسيًا عالميًا جديدًا ، لكن هذا الحب لا يزال جيدًا السيد Koide
الأنشطة مهمة أيضًا ، ولكن من هؤلاء العملاء
حسنًا ، إذا وصل صوت سعيد ، فسيكون صوتًا آخر
هل هو شعور بالإنجاز يؤدي إلى الشعور بالرضا.
بعد كل شيء ، بالنسبة لي ، فإن Nishiki-koi مثل أطفالي.
عندما أرى الأطفال يكبرون ويصبحون جميلين ، يكون الأمر كذلك حقًا
أنا سعيد
[موسيقى]